Sarah Paulsen's performance as Marcia  Clark in the People vs OJ Simpson is  creating a lot of buzz but it's her  on-screen chemistry with sterling K  Brown as Christopher Darden that has  fueled rumors that Clark and Darden  weren't item in real life what was your  take on what their relationship might  have been um I have my own tape sterling  has his own take we discussed it we were  in agreement and that was good but  Marcia and Chris never made any  confirmation about any of that so we  certainly weren't going to put that out  as fact but you know it felt to me like  there was something going on with et sat  down with Clark last September she had  this to say about her former colleague  Chris and I were trench mates he kept me  from just utter depression so many days  where Paulson one thing is certain that  her co-star is a hottie  sterling is real hot smoking hot